tell us what is ultra egos the film
about it oh uh well they're kind of
there's kind of an a story and a b story
so I can tell my side of the story and
you can tell your side of the story I
like to think of my side as the
a I don't think that's the a story Drive
the film okay a story my side of the
story is about uh
superheroes uh exist and they have kind
of captured they've captured all the
super villains and and have kind of
outstay they welcome in society and so
people the society is kind of kind of
getting tired of them and they're also
very getting tired of um spending their
tax money to fund the superheroes so the
government is going to kind of cut their
funding soon so the superheroes have to
come up with a plan to become relevant
again so seethrough that's my character
um and he's fridge and we're kind of
like the lower Echelon of the super core
you know kind of the the the foot
soldiers and so I'm transporting a uh a
super villain to a new facility and so
I've got a scheme that I'm actually
being the head of the super core is
making me kind of go through with this
and I have to kind of trap my best
friend see-through into kind of doing
this um event which I don't want to give
away but shall I give it away and that's
just the first two minutes of the movie
then after that you're out of those no
I'm actually in the movie anymore after
that yeah I don't think we ever met
before I'm
chriset like a lot of most of the
time what's what my end of it well the
the be side of the story is uh I I'm
fridge you know this this superhero on
one hand who's come out to the Hamptons
to deal with this uh this plot that
see-throughs kind of hatched to um to
get our funding back uh and at the same
time uh I'm dealing with a personal
crisis which is that um my Alter Ego or
my real self Brendan who's just you know
human civilian guy uh is having
girlfriend problems and um I decide that
I'm going to uh dress up and hit on my
own girlfriend as fridge uh and uh and
she starts having an affair with me so
I'm cheating on myself with myself uh
and I'm having a bit of a uh crisis
about that not knowing who she really
likes more whether it's the real me but
who is the real me is it the guy in the
blue tights who can shoot ice out of his
hands or is it the the normal little
comic sketching dweeb who lives with his
girlfriend and then as the movie sort of
uh goes on all these things you know see
through his crazy plot and my personal
crisis kind of intertwine and caution
anig and what other types of superpowers
do you have besides the the shooting of
ice
what what do you only have one
superpower I don't know if you know this
that's why we work together in super and
they're pretty they're kind of realistic
so he he can shoot ice and my character
can simply see through things he's hence
see through he can only just you can
read lips pretty well too yeah but
that's more of an acquired skill I don't
know that's necessarily like a super and
I can read really fast but that's also
something that I not really fast like
not faster than the average person but I
can I can read pretty quickly but that
was also not never movie me though that
was just something that you something
had on your own that didn't make it into
no one talked about that yeah that was
never brought up in the film does he
move his lips when he moves or is he
actually so skilled that he doesn't move
his lip I don't know I need to get a
mirror out I thought of your character
is illiterate and I think it kind of
come across that way in the what did I
say I said I could read really fast
maybe it maybe it's that I'm illiterate
maybe that's my other that could be my
other my other superpower is is is
illiteracy illiteracy fighting
illiteracy with illiteracy exactly I'm
going to we should write can we write
that down as I know there's a t-shirt
idea maybe in the future fighting
illiteracy with illiteracy Joey Kern's
kid
project Kern's
kids can't read K's kids can't quite
read all
okay and for
see-through
read cre remember those x-ray glasses is
that something part of his thing or no
he can actually that's more of his dis
totally unnecessary that's something he
just would bring to set every
day yellow glasses and he just sneak
them on oops is the camera rolling no we
needed something because he had the mask
and so you needed we needed something to
kind of say okay this guy's Incognito um
because but you never see you don't
really see my character I I guess you
see him outside of this costume but just
at the beginning and the end of the film
so we needed something to when he's in
public you know he but it became kind of
a nuisance because the camera would
always reflect on the on the plastic of
the go of the goggles yeah Chris l s of
the DP he really hated those glasses and
it sucked for me too because I would
have to kind of tilt my head and he'd
say okay I can't see the camera now and
then I would have to do the scene
without moving my head too much so that
the reflection of the but I I have
amazing Stillness a lot of people have
asked me is Joey playing a robot in this
movie with a this uh with a tilted head
issue and I had to explain to them no no
you are not a robot in this film I feel
like I look really natural when I do it
yeah a little bit robotic little robotic
actually a natural robot sometimes
people start messing with the because
they think the the frame is frozen in
the the Stillness of that odd just a
very odd thing that you had to do weird
well when it's the a story you know I
mean you really got to ground the film I
feel that grounded it next question
how did the two of you become involved
with alter egos did you have to audition
were you just chosen Were You The Chosen
we were actually it was actually written
for us uh we had worked with Jordan
Gallen before in his first film and um
when he sat down to kind of start this
process with with alter egos he wrote it
with us in mind and I think he kind of
touched base with us before he even
really started writing it to kind of
pitch the idea to us and see if we um if
we if it kind of spoke to us and kind of
you know help let us kind of um
influence where we thought we wanted our
characters to kind of go with it so yeah
we kind of involved from the from the
get-go with it it was
nice ditto that is true that is true
what he says is true it yeah we were
involved I remember it was right around
uh Christmas time I feel like I'm
talking to Jordan almost daily yeah
however however many years ago this was
about he would you know email the script
over over and then you would have ideas
about it and Jordan would contribute
like change it a little bit and I'd read
it and we'd get on the phone and we'
change he was you know we were going
back and forth and talking almost daily
for a while there and he he um I think
he really wanted to make sure that you
and I both wanted to do it because
that that was a big part of actually
doing the whole film was that he just
with the three of us were going to get
together again and when we worked on the
movie the first film that Joy was
talking about Rosen CR and Gilden Stern
are Undead I uh we we had I mean at
least speaking for myself I we had I had
such a great time working on that movie
and working with Jordan and I love the
way Jordan works and I I really thought
the movie was funny and and um and I
think he did too and I'm sure you had a
good time and so it was just like really
kind of like hungry to like get back and
just I mean I would have done if Jordan
had said I have no script whatsoever
we're going out to the middle of the
desert we'll be shooting for 3 months I
don't know we may never come back I
would have said all right let's do it
why not she just has a great atmosphere
love working with Jordan yeah it it was
we we had a good time we were able to
kind of mess around with the script a
little bit and you know um do a couple
takes that were a little bit looser and
you know so it was it was it was it was
easy we have a lot of fun with each
other so how did Kevin Smith and the
smart cast get involved with uh Ultra
Egos and what kind of support do they
offer I have no idea I I don't know how
they got involved they they Kevin
Smith's modcast has a deal with phase 4
who acquired our film and they are
partnering up on a certain number of
films and so uh yeah Kevin you know
Smith has tweeted about it a number of
times which I think you know he's got a
legion of fans that um but I don't know
specifically you know how much how much
Kevin has personally been involved I
mean I know putting his name on it is
one of the first things most people even
mention to me about the movie so that
just in and of itself has been a major
boo Boo for the movie it's just him
saying Kevin Smith presents putting it
on a poster putting it on a trailer
people get very excited he's got a
really dedicated group of folks that
follow him and love him and you know are
waiting for whatever he's you know got
coming next so that's been nice and I
think he's looking for now in his career
from what I understand is that he's
trying to um help push and and and
generate um younger uh filmmakers that
kind of kind of how he started and so
Jordan Gallum is is kind of one of those
and I think he's excited about Kevin's
been excited about you know promoting
our film and you know like Chris has his
Legion of fans and and that's that's
really helped us I think for sure have
either of you been to the SM Castle the
SM Castle I didn't know there was such a
thing as a SM Castle what I get on the
phone my manager right now why haven't I
been to the SM Castle well you mentioned
Twitter are either of you on Twitter and
if you are what's your regularity in TW
I'm not on Twitter so I can get that out
of the way right
away that's that's a no no uh no I don't
I read Twitter for for some news but I
don't really tweet very often I have a
Facebook page that um I've been touting
alter OS a lot and that that's you know
it's been kind of fun to hear people's
reactions um but I don't really do I
don't think either of us do a whole lot
of like self-promoting in that Arena do
you think that's part of an actor's job
in terms of being a part of a project
are they there just to be on set and to
then when they're done walk away or
continue with promoting it well I think
obviously we you know we enjoy promoting
and that's why we're here so I I don't I
do not enjoy well promoting it you're
not very good at
it I don't think it's part of the
actor's job to be honest I think it is
for it is now it's expected of actors a
lot more and I and I think that uh it's
understood to be part of an actor's job
so saying that technically now it it's
part and parcel of when you sign on to
do a movie you are expected to be doing
a certain amount of promotion me
personally though I don't think that's
the way it should be and I don't think
it is part of an actor's job I think an
actor primarily is there to be
performing and do a great job and on set
and then that's when your job ends
you're like Mr Pink and and Reservoir
Dogs I don't believe in tipping no it's
for the bird you know I me I was just
thinking about that scene just today it
has no similarity what I'm saying right
now it's very similar no it's not
nothing you look like Mr P how much I
look like Mr Pink you look a lot like
Steve in a dental way mostly tipping is
very tipping is very very important
thing to do not promoting though however
on the other hand he promotes like crazy
never tips never not never won't won put
a tip down for anybody I think that you
know if you do a studio film it's it's
in your contract you have to do you know
I'm not debating that you you're
expected to do it and it is in your
contract I'm just saying I don't think
it is part of an actor's job
theoretically speaking but it is in
reality totally part of your job now
well I mean everyone wants their film to
be to be exposed and to you know to get
out there and I think that actors
nowadays have how much good do you think
promoting does for an actor though to
for a film like are you watching TV and
you see this interview on TV do you go
out and watch alter Ricos because of you
and me sitting on the couch well I think
that I probably yeah maybe more so than
if I see if I don't see that I kind of
feel like it's just like it's said you
guys probably know better than me but I
think it's sort of just a
self-supporting industry where it's just
people are you know we're actors we're
looking to self-promote and to a certain
extent you guys need someone to
interview and you just every we all sort
of work together and and and basically
take up space in this world but we don't
we we I don't know how much good this
does for uh the film well I think that
if you if you see if if there's an actor
that promotes a film it it makes you
think oh you know what I like that actor
he really likes this film I'm I'm going
to to go see it because if this person
genuine I mean you I'm not allowed to
you know if I'm Johnny Depp for example
and I go on some late night talk show
that's going to have a wide audience of
people watching it I'm not allowed to
say I hated this movie so it's
disingenuous everybody says I love the
movie so no one's even paying attention
there's different but you can you can
kind of tell you can tell when an actor
likes or doesn't like a film you know
they you can they can you can kind of by
that rationale then if you're expecting
an actor to promote and he doesn't
actually like the movie then he's doing
the film a dis by going and promoting it
I think that that's why sometimes they
they ask an actor not to do that or or a
big time actor may say look I don't like
this film I'm not going to be very good
at promoting it so don't ask me to go do
these these interviews I mean look at
Leonardo cako how often do you see him
do interviews and things like that very
very rarely and I think it's I don't
know but I imagine it's because he hates
he no I imagine because he doesn't enjoy
doing terrible movies and it's not going
to help I don't know uh yeah interesting
I mean I always think that when you
reach a certain level of Fame then if
you really hate going out and doing the
talk shows and everything you can
finally just say I'm not doing it and
nobody cares because you're a big enough
name at that point in time anyways true
but every Studio would want you know
even the bigger the bigger the better
they want that that person to go no no
doubt about it I know they all want that
I think that's one of the reasons Johnny
Depp is the Mega star that he is is his
willingness to just promote promote
promote promote promote exactly do you
feel though that beefing up your social
media might help in some sense it seems
like casting directors and and even
studios are looking at people's Twitter
following and even like people are
paying to beef up their imgb meter yeah
wow really I know that this
amazing starer how do I get them what do
I do I pay to beef up the star meter who
do I pay IMDb or do I pay like thousands
of people to go and click on my page no
you got to it's like that meter is is I
think um five people that like look you
up online or at certain on certain
engines and stuff and so I think it uh
interesting how how boost up is your
Twitter account how many people are you
paying to boost your Twitter account a
lot I'd say yeah I'd say I'd say that
you have a lot of Twitter followers
Rosco tweets 750 times a day most of
them are just Single Character tweets
like an N or a p but he's twe more like
something on the sometimes you get that
yeah uh I think that that that a lot of
actors out there are really great
self-promoters and and directors and
things like that and I think that that's
great you know what I mean if that's how
if they feel like that's how they need
their to help their careers that's
fantastic I I I hope that that doesn't
become the norm you know and I hope that
that doesn't um I mean you know it's
it's business well correct me if I'm
wrong like just to get back to what we
were talking about before doesn't a
certain amount of self-promotion turn
you off like don't you think the best
form of self-promotion is making good
stuff and that when you when you have a
certain friend you know we don't need to
mention names or anything but friend X
or something who every time he does
anything you get a text saying like Joey
I'm so proud of this movie I made please
come out and support please turn into
CBS at 9:00 p.m. to watch this come to
my art shirt whatever and it it's always
sort of mediocre stuff don't you kind of
just look at it and kind of disregard it
eventually and think like oh God all
this guy does white definitely so I I
don't know see I I I think that the best
form of promotion is is good work and
then you know all the I I feel like
there there's got to be a lot of people
who feel like me and feel like you about
this that when self-promotion is kind of
a turnoff it makes me it takes sort of a
notch off my desire to sort of be uh a
spectator with whatever they're sort of
trying to shove down my throat I I I
feel like sort of you
know letting the work speak for itself
is one of the more appealing things
about about an artist or or anybody
who's in the entertainment business
whether they're an artist or not
um making good work is is great and if
somebody's really trying to force me to
see their work it makes me suspicious
about how good the work could possibly
be yeah but I think also even now it
goes beyond the work and it's about
people kind of letting others into their
lives you know well true yeah that's a
whole tweeting and and saying like well
you know just got out of the guitar
store I'm going to go play my guitar now
at the gym and then all these like like
tweeners are like oh my God he plays a
guitar you know and it's it's it it has
nothing to do with their well that's
really unfair cuz I was just writing
that I play the guitar because I just
wanted people to know you know I wasn't
necessarily riding for all those
tweeners yeah but God bless you it's
really nice that response is just always
great do you think there's a way to
Tastefully promote where it's not that
used car salesman element where it
doesn't seem so squeezy but then still
getting the word out that hey Ultra egos
is playing at
the I think the like what what I was
saying the only way to to Tastefully
self promote I think is if you make good
work first and foremost and you are
legitimately proud of something and then
you are not a reckless self-promoter to
begin with if you very rarely hit me up
and you know tweet or text me or
whatever that that one moment when you
do call me up and say hey um I made this
thing I'm really proud of it um I would
love for you to go see it because I
think you're going to really enjoy it
and I I want people to see it I'm really
proud of this it means a lot to me I
would say wow okay great this is
obviously something that's really
important to Joe and I'll go see it um
to me the only way to really Tastefully
promote is to very rarely self-promote
it's got to be it just has to be genuine
and and if you if if you're convinced
that your every single droplet of sweat
that comes off of your body is brilliant
and and worth me inspecting under a
microscope uh I'm probably not going to
be on board when you when you you know
promote the one thing that's actually
really good yeah but but also I mean to
play Devil's Advocate I think that you
know if I have a Twitter account and and
I do I don't have many followers but uh
but if I were trying to get followers
people that are are following my Twitter
account they are specifically following
it so that they can get information they
want to know everything that I'm doing
and you know and you can make the
information I give a a give out can be
you know just like business like hey
I've got this new film out I I really
like it here's a clip from it here's an
article you know here's a link to a to
an interview I did kind of thing people
people that are following me that's why
they're following they I see what you're
saying if you do have a Twitter account
that basically is just an it's it's it's
an arm of your promotional machine yeah
if I text you you know what I mean like
like if if I text you that's annoying
you know what I mean cuz then I'm just
kind of like getting in your space and
you're not I guess maybe I even
misunderstand what Twitter is even for
maybe that is what Twitter's for maybe
TW people are just expecting Twitter to
just be this kind of barrage of they
they follow people for specific reasons
and you can always unfollow somebody you
know so I so I'm following you on
Twitter because I want you to be
tweeting things like hey guys new
television shows coming out hey guys I'm
on yes uh CSI this week or hey guys I
follow like Louis CK on Twitter cuz he
may say hey a whole new batch of tickets
just opened up for the LA show you know
and like here's a link to go get him
right you know and then I'm like one of
the first you know I that's that's the
first information that's being put out
it's like instant instant information I
may not be properly qualified to comment
on Twitter then I don't spend enough
time on Twitter OB to really know what
it's about what if there comes a point
in both your careers where you'll be
required to divulge personal things on
social media as a way of keeping people
even more in the loop about your
brand that was the most terrifying
sentence I have ever heard in my entire
life I know that there were words that
you put together there that just I tuned
out halfway through and a sense of
horror just invaded my stomach we're not
reality stars I got so terrified I I
need the cat can I hold the cat I need
to cuddle the cat I'll hold you I'll
hold I got you no one's going to know
anything about you no one's going to
need to know anything about
you when did you start sucking your
thumb I about two weeks ago actually I
highly recommend it do you feel like
maybe that's bad don't Deva to that to
anyone I'm assuming the answer then is
that's that wouldn't be I tell you but
there's a siren the police are on their
way you want to jump in this what we
were talking about um divulging personal
information about yourself too to
somehow increase the appeal of your
brand yeah I think that that's fine a as
long what's your brand this oo I like it
I'll take it I think as long as it's not
if as long as it's not real as long as
it's not true people can know anything
they want to know about me you know
explain that sentence well if it makes
it makes someone feel like they like me
better cuz they cuz they know that I can
so someone was going to say something
like a lie about you like Joey Kern's a
womanizer not that you're not I want
that I would want to be derogatory but
if someone said like oh Joey eats like
French toast every morning you know and
that's not true but if that makes
someone like me more and they go go rent
my movie then that's fine if they they
want but I think it's much more likely
that people are going to have sort of
the those those sort of salacious kind
of uh details about you are much more
appealing that's the stuff that's gonna
get around well that's true or not yeah
but that that's out of my control you
know what I mean if people feel like
they need to know that information about
people but would you ever dege it
yourself like if you felt if your if
your publicist was like Joey if you come
forward and you confess your drug
problem or marital infidelity whatever
that's good people are going to love you
for that you're right yeah I got to
agree with
that I think I don't think anyone should
do that if they I think Terence Malik
does it I think in terms of people
who've handled their career in publicity
wise I think Terence Malik does a
wonderful job why cuz you don't know
anything about it well because he
doesn't feel to me that doesn't seem me
feels an obligation to go out
and I feel like he doesn't feel an
obligation to go to go out and promote
and make appearances and divulge
personal details about himself but still
I know his name and you know his name
I'm sure everybody here knows name very
very popular guy he I mean in terms of
you know in his career makes you know
movies get works with great people has a
lot of money for his films his films
make a decent amount of money he he
seems to sort of sidestep that machine
the publicity machine altoe and it
doesn't seem to hurt him at all I think
it's also I agree with you and I think
it's it's it's very detrimental for an
actor to for people to know too much
about them personally because we play
characters you know and and every
character we play we bring a little bit
of ourselves to you have to but if
someone knows too much about me they
won't be able to watch me on film and
say oh I'm losing myself that's that
character you know sometimes and I think
he's a great actor but Tom Cruz I watch
Tom Cruz now and I don't necessarily
watch um the character that he's playing
you know because I know too much about
his personal life and it's interesting I
mean it's D it's a danger that I guess
can happen to any actor if you become
famous enough in this era anyone's going
to want to know personal things about
you and it's very difficult to keep
those things close to the chest anymore
I think it it it's detrimental to an
actor their career it's it's like when
when you're watching a friend we have a
lot of friends that are actors and when
you're watching them sometimes it's hard
to Lose Yourself and see them cuz you
know them too well to really lose
yourself character yeah totally agree
yeah you just always want to call
[__] yeah because you're like you're
not a tough guy you're not Sho look at
you pointing a gun you know what you're
doing but everyone around you was like
watch oh my God that guy's terrifying
yeah have you ever felt a uh
competitiveness from other actors at
auditions and if so how do you handle
that suppose you walk into a room and
there's like 10 of you there how do you
keep that game face on so that you don't
let them I mean it's just human nature
to probably
feel you know I think it's kind of silly
for actors to be to be competitive with
each other I mean everyone's nervous in
that situation and the audition room has
a unique kind of uh tension to it
anyways but you know you're really not
competing against each other you know
you're kind of competing against
yourself and so I think when people do
get competitive they try to psych the
other person out you know and I think
that's just kind of dirty but from my
experience I don't think guys I don't
think men do it very often but I've
heard that females in in the audition
room can can kind of get kind of nasty
some of them I think they feel a little
bit more competitive than than dudes
don't you
think yeah I haven't experienced too
much I every once in a while I've seen
somebody in an audition room doing
something so odd and kind of obnoxious
that I thought to myself maybe that guy
is trying to psych everybody else out or
distract me or do something like that uh
but no typically I agree with you that
it's more everybody's kind of in their
own universe and and they're nervous for
their own reasons and you're more trying
to do your own thing as best as you can
possibly do it um and uh there's enough
ways that people are going to
self-destruct on their own they don't
need help from anybody outse in audition
auditions are incredibly stressful
difficult situations I feel like most
people are
worried enough about their own thing or
at least concentrated enough on their
own thing to not be thinking about how
to mess up the guy next to you it's just
sort of a at least in my experience but
maybe I don't know maybe you and I I
would like if it was more competitive if
they're like all right we're going to
bring you guys in or now you do it all
right now you do it all right take your
tops off and fight when you're done with
that we'll go in the audition r i I like
to come out of the audition room and be
like all right great no I'll have my
agent read the contracts then all right
I can't wait I'll see you guys on set
that does happen good luck everybody hey
good luck everybody there is some psych
out that goes on with like the guy who
walks out of the room everyone's
watching what he's doing know there's a
guy who comes out with his sides and
immediately throws him in the trash just
throws him in the trash and storming out
and you're like okay well that maybe it
didn't go so well then there's a guy
that comes out and he's just so he's
like all right guys huh everybody great
break a leg guys break a leg break leg
break a leg you're like well [__] you
[__] uh but you know who you are you
know who you are break a leg guy stop
saying it stop saying it that's it so
what's your process when you do leave
after you hear great work great job
thank you we have your information do
you obsess I tweet it
instantly I tweet going to gym had
rocked that audition just cried
internally uh I don't know just degraded
myself I have definitely been that guy
that walks out and has like ripped the
pages you know all my way out and and I
book that job sometimes I have yeah you
know you just you just don't know it's
so awful sometimes as an actor you know
walking into a room it's like having a
job interview that's what I equated it
to I think everyone most people can
understand what a job interview is like
but it's one of those job interviews
where they say oh my God you're perfect
for this job you have the wrong hair
color so you can't be the president of
the United States kind of thing um and
it's it's kind of depressing in in that
way but it um I think you train yourself
as an actor to Once you walk out that
door you forget about it you totally
I've been called and said hey I know how
good you are that I'm good at that I had
up been call me like you had an audition
you got that job like what job like it's
for this movie and like I don't remember
what that was and they like it's this
remember you audition for it last week
and I have to like kind of go through my
notes and be like oh cool yeah no I
remember that cuz I've trained myself to
just not care cuz you it just eat you
you know oh yeah I'm I'm I haven't I've
got to actually you should maybe do a
class that I could take and train myself
to not care cuz I still I'm I'm very
tortured by the whole thing auditioning
for me is a horribly painful difficult
thing I always say to myself uh and
other people too and now anyone who
listen um that if and when I get to a
point where I'm you know creatively in
control of a project in terms of casting
and hiring people that I just want to
revolutionize the audition process cuz I
think it's a totally it's not a very
constructive it's
process and you're not really finding
the best people for the work you're kind
of just finding good auditioners which
isn't reflective
yeah set so I'd just like to I think the
whole thing needs to change I I don't I
I don't I think it's it's it's gotten to
a really weird place I think people are
also lazy with um on the other side of
the camera they're lazy with watching
someone's real with watching someone's
previous work you know I I I wouldn't
hire somebody you know I wouldn't even
ask someone to come in and and take an
interview unless I'd read a resume you
know and and kind of you know read you
know if I was read some of the the the
what they've done you know um I think
it's it's kind of a lazy thing and and
people just want to hear their own
material coming out of that person's
mouth and I I think that you know
there's there's room for that but I
always equated it's like have
auditioning is kind of like having a
math teacher give an English test you
know they're both teachers but it's a
whole different subject you know
I'm waiting I mean I'm waiting to find
out if one day I'm somebody who has to
thank you thanks that's that's good
that's not distracting at all actually
this is there are a lot of sirens around
here
I like to keep but I I'm waiting to find
out like one day if I'm in that position
where I'm directing or producing
something and um if and when I I'm
waiting to find out that maybe there's a
reason why the casting process is to me
what seems very backward and weird but
there there might be a reason I mean I
might be that guy sitting there there
thinking like I just don't have time to
do this I can't read everybody's resume
I can't watch your real I'm trying to do
things and just you know and and and I
don't care who the best actor is I'm
just waiting for someone to come in the
room and not melt down and right you can
have the role I just need to get this
movie made you know and I everybody I
guess is stressed out in their own way
but to me right now from somebody who
strictly has seen the audition process
from the point of the
auditioner uh right not the audition e
am I the audition e or am I the audition
ER I'm the audition e well the audition
is the person who's auditioning me right
and I am auditioning so I am the
audition audition doesn't matter uh from
the point of view of the actor who's
going in on and auditioning um we'll
just cut that out uh start
now and that's what I
think um yeah it's it seems weird to me
I don't like I don't like the process
this was an audition right now oh good
did I get the roll no I didn't didn't
get it didn't get it
do you think anybody have some sides
that can rip up and throw in the trash
these were the sides oh D you said every
word wrong oh boy oh boy that
hurts but I was going to say this is
like it's this you know this another
phenomenon about auditioning that's
hilarious is when you are in the room
and you're waiting and there's a person
goes in and it's 25 minutes that person
they come out and do thing like okay
good the next person goes in and 15 20
minutes go by and you of the time that
each guy is spending in the room and you
get in there and suddenly you do it and
you feel like okay that well like great
thanks you done like one scene and
you're done and you walk out the room
there's that a that feeling where you're
thinking to yourself what the hell I was
in there for like 3 minutes maybe is it
just you and then you try to rationalize
it you're like maybe time just seemed to
pass really quickly cuz I was in the
auditioning room but when I'm outside of
the room then maybe it doesn't and then
there's the Walk of Shame to go get your
like keys and like I think CU all the
guys like wow every other guy was in
there for 20 minutes in for about5
seconds what happened to you and I
always try to also rationalize I'm like
okay either they think I did a really
bad job or maybe I did so amazing that
they can't CH that there's nothing we
can say I yeah that's the worst I um
forgot what I was going to say about
audition it sounds good though I think
that's all we need I think we got enough
from you there I think that's pretty
solid what wasn't going to say um about
like you can like hear the other people
on the audition that
is when you're like comedy bit about
that sorry but you did a comedy bit
about hearing oh yeah did you see that
on yeah I do like some stand up about it
yeah um about like people that walk in
and try to kind of Psych you out you
know like the guy that that comes in
with like a motorcycle helmet although
he like drove his car there you know
he's like all tussled and he's like oh I
need to put my motorcycle down on this
chair my motorcycle helmet down on this
chair because it needs its own space you
know and and the whole idea of like here
hearing someone cuz it's like it like
psyches you out a little bit and stuff
go watch it it's on YouTube I'll watch
it yeah I'll Che it that I like it I
want to say something you feel
self-conscious about though in those
rooms where you know the walls are so
thin I had an audition where it was all
girls and I was the only one reading
this one guy's part and all the girls
parts were just very conversational but
they would go in the room and I could
word for word hear the talking just
being like well Molly I think we should
go to the store and buy bread really
yeah we need some bread like just I'm
like hear everything you're saying and
then yours is like a SC might scream be
like no God damn it no please just have
mercy on me and it's like three days of
like crying and scream and I get in the
room I'm just thinking of all these
girls out there in the room being like
oh great here we
go that's the wor but that is kind of a
process of where you have to willfully
be able to just shut down a certain part
of your brain and say like all right
screw it I'm not going to be
concentrating on that I'm going to
concentrate on this exclusively which
you can do with varying levels of
success I find find that when you know
people always say oh it's so that that
actor's so brave you know in their work
and I and I find that you know there
there is a lot of um um bravery and and
and and commitment that takes when
you're when you're actually working but
I feel like auditioning it takes so much
more bravery because you're putting
yourself out there for someone to say
you you you did a good job or you did a
bad job you know with even more so than
um than acting you know when you
actually have the job when you're
auditioning you're you know you can tell
right away when someone you know it's
like oh okay oh all right thanks a lot
thanks for coming in you know you can
tell right away oh that person didn't
like that what I just did my choices you
know and and it's so I don't know it
takes a lot more
um huta to kind of go in an audition
than than actually having the job it's
and it's I think it's a totally
different skill set auditioning and then
doing the work yeah they're they're
related in certain respects but they're
very very different and I think I think
some people like we were saying before
are incredibly good at auditioning and
then not necessarily that great as a
performer at the end of the day um and
vice versa there are people who just
absolutely can't audition but are really
nice actors at the end of the day um and
it it's it's just it's it's strange that
that is the portal that you have to walk
through in order to be able to do the
work and it's it's almost like you know
and they they do classes where they you
know there's classes about acting
classes then there are specific here is
on an auditioning class and the things
to do and not to do I I was studed at
NYU and I wish we had had auditioning
class we never had audition it's
probably invaluable I think it is I
think I have you ever gone in and sat in
a casting office as a volunteer to read
and things like that just to see what
see I've always wanted to never done it
apparently it's incredibly disturbing no
it's it's I me informative but you also
see like you see things and you realize
very quickly that oh that actor should
not have oh God he's already [__]
himself he just he started reading the
lines yet he's walked in yeah you you
you see that it's it's good to just kind
of walk in you know be kind of neutral
say hi don't try to do too much and just
do your thing and walk out right you
know and some I have I've been on the
other side of on on the other side of
the camera and it is it is very
interesting it is very um what do you
think is the number one can if you could
even say this the number one mistake
that actors make when they go into like
you you could say like don't do this
please I I think the the just kind of a
general note I think it's it's and I and
I've been guilty of this is is trying
too much trying to be their best friend
trying to crack too many jokes um trying
to uh you know letting your nerves kind
of take over and and trying to distract
you know from that I think it's best to
just kind of come in hey how are you you
know let me let me do this and um do you
think it's important to have your lines
memorized do it bother you people are
just reading off a page if they're doing
a great job
I you I think that if you're doing it
depends on the what you're what you're
doing but yeah no I think definitely
should be memorized I think you should
always hold your your script but I think
you know I'm always memorized you know I
think that that definitely um I am too
but sometimes I just feel like maybe if
I was less concerned and I just went in
there and just casually just held the
piece of paper that just look like a
badass like you doesn't give a [__] just
want and and and not necessarily be
concerned about getting the lines right
not NE so no you're you're getting L
right cuz they're there you're just
reading them off the page you're just
not so concerned with having it
memorized and like having created a
performance you know you're kind of just
in there just doing the thing with the
reader well I think I think I think yeah
I think at the end of the day you have
to walk in and you know even if you if
you rehears and rehearsed and rehears it
I think at the end of the day you had to
go in and just you know do it with a
performer you know do it with the other
the the reader you know I think that and
I've been guilty of this just kind of
like making it what I you know here's my
audition I shaped it like this this is
is exactly what I want to bring in and I
bring it in and it's there's no life to
it you know maybe I hit the Beats right
but there there's no life to it you know
dising is so weird that's another thing
I mean you're reading with somebody who
typically is not another actor and
they're like reading like this a piece
of paper and then I love you too but why
did you kill my father that's how I was
going to do the scene though anyways
when I did that piece I remember the one
you're talking about I did it exactly
like that yeah yeah nailed it nailed it
do you think Hollywood is made made up
of a large group of class
clowns were you all class clowns growing
up or were you more the introverted one
watching from afar H it's an interesting
question
silently
thinking judging
Jud I think that Hollywood is made up of
um every single type of person I don't
think that that that I think that that's
why we go to see movies I think that we
don't um or you know watch TV
everybody's different you know and I
think that um I think for the most part
people in Hollywood have learned that
they are a little bit um they have to be
energetic you know and and but that
doesn't necess mean that they're they're
not introverts I think they're a lot of
introverts here I think that I think
there's every every type here you know I
think that that's why um I think that
that's why there there's
diversity I'm Joey Kern I approve this
message I'm Joey Kern I approve
Hollywood yeah what do you think Chris
you have anything to add to I don't know
I don't I think yeah you don't really
have any friends you don't really get
out don't do this's a lot of talking
I've done here to first time people have
been talking your vocal board still work
yeah it's sore you know what it needs a
beer would be really nice someone don't
get drunk um yeah I think that there's I
agree I mean that is as cheesy as it was
phrased I think it's there definitely
this true that it is made made up of
there's there's a wide variety of people
here there are a lot of it's what's
what's interesting to me is that I I
sometimes find that there are different
types of people who will look down on
another group of people for their
motivations in doing what they're doing
and the entertainment industry there are
a lot of class clowns there are a lot of
people who are just like look at me I
just want people to look at me I just
want to be looked at and admired and and
loved and then there are people who are
stereotypically a little bit more
introverted and and are say I don't you
know I want to make good work I want to
make challenging truthful work and it's
not about who's looking at me it's about
what I'm bringing forward and I often
find that the people who feel that way
about truth and beauty and being you
know honest and always look down on
those people who are just like I just
want to I I'm just trying to have a good
time um and the people who are trying to
have a good time are always looking down
on the people who are just trying to
sort of pull something out of the muck
um
and uh I think it's a really cheesy way
of putting it it's it's um well I was
trying to keep it in the same
veins this yeah I didn't wanted I didn't
want to leap off too far I wanted just
you know we get go cut this together at
some point what if that trash man is
going to try to come take you
[Laughter]
away he might might he might um but yeah
that's I don't know where I was going
with that well you said that you feel
that Hollywood respects people that are
really almost Uber extroverts that just
like on level 10 and and what if you're
in a mood where you're not in that space
at all you're almost like 10 introverted
right how do you psych yourself out how
do you get into that mode without
alcohol or any other substances oh
without substances oh I don't know I
don't even think there's any way to
answer that question more
sleep the audition don't go don't go
don't go don't go outside of your house
um I'd recommend in Los Angeles never to
leave your house without drugs or
alcohol ever you'll really hurt yourself
it's pretty bad out there it's pretty
horrible you should be pretty
medicated well medicated maybe yeah um
any I think that's that's part of our
job you know I mean part of our job is
to is to uh I think our job is to
fulfill what the writer has written and
so and so if the if the the job is to
you know this character is supposed to
be you know energetic and and number 10
at a 10 and you're feel like you know
that day for the audition you feel like
I'm at a negative 10 that's why we you
know that's why we studied acting you
know and not not not that you have to
but I think that that's you use your
Technique to get to that place where
you're like okay you know what I I'm not
feeling this today but I'm going to go
through these steps you know this is my
process to try to get me to that
place you think yeah no I think I think
that's right yeah that's why that's the
that's the that's the professional
element to it that's being a pro there A
lot of times you don't feel like you
want to be it's a weird job I me there A
lot of times you not only do not feel
like I don't have the energy to do this
to to go out and you know Play a scene
where I'm this laughy funny guy who's
making everybody in the room laugh not
only do I not feel like doing that some
days you're like I don't want anyone to
look at me today like I just want to
crawl under a hole and put a blanket
over my head and and and you've got
people fixing your hair and they're
doing and it's just the there's the
there's the the room you know in
suddenly everything goes quiet and the
camera's rolling and the eyes of not all
the not only all the people in the scene
but the whole crew is just sort of being
like waiting for this scene to take
place it's really it's pretty it can it
can be a very invasive and and bad
feeling sometimes and it's part of being
a pro where you just have to kind of
suck it up and and do it anyway yeah I
always say though I think that working
is actually vacation for me you know
when I'm when I'm not working when I'm
unemployed that's really when my work
starts you know that's when I have to
try to get it that's when I have to like
you know focus on getting a job and
those that's tough you know like being
unemployed as an actor it those times
it's awful it's tough and so when I
actually do work that's when I can kind
of relax and just have fun and like this
is what I this is what I want to do you
know this is why I I go through those
those those grueling times of not
working you know and so for me that's
just that's just that's the that's the
sugar on top you know whenever I do get
the chance to actually work it's great
should an actor rely on their agent to
get them
work should he or yes I fired my agent
so I'm screwed I think that no I think
that um an an agent uh in in this
business is is a um is a a great
commodity to have you know I thought
you're going to say necessary Evil part
with the words you're going to use no I
I think that that agents can can the
agents that work well that are you know
good at their job they um get you
opportunities you know they get you in
the rooms and they can they pitch you
and they talk to the people to producers
and casting directors mostly to you know
get you seen for for these auditions um
that being said I would say that 85% of
my work that I do in my career has been
on gone on my own um just from
relationships and and you know there's
so many small movies being made now that
people just kind of call up and say hey
I'm making this movie it's you know a
couple hundred grand there's going to be
a lot of police chases in it and the
police will maybe come after you and I
can see it right now I feel like I'm
there I sometimes just imagine
that really just paint a real picture a
Sonic landscape to use the the Natural
soundtrack of you do you did well than
hey great job when is that work involved
let's suppose you're going through a
down period where work's not coming in
maybe nothing's no emails from the agent
or call so what type of things do you
both do to drum up work for
yourselves I I WR I prefer not working
so I'm just when the phone's not ringing
if you got to get out of the way maybe
you should move out out of LA and maybe
get out of the way so other people that
want to work they could take those jobs
yeah yeah okay I'll think about it think
about that or next time you book a job
you're like hey I'll pass give it to
Joey give it to Joey I'll take it I eat
it up
drob delicious ter yeah sorry it was on
the ground for a b yeah your jobs are
always on the ground
um what did you
ask so what what types of things do you
do what do you do what do you do to
drama for oh you right I have a big
drama no I uh I write you know I think
that I I go out and do some standup now
and then just to kind of I like to be
and get up and and um and just perform
uh you know so stand up helps or I do
improv a little bit um take class you
know just to kind of keep my motor
running but uh in terms of drumming on
my own work um Beyond writing and things
like that uh just relationships you know
just kind of being out and and and going
to screenings and and film festivals are
great when we get to go to film
festivals you meet a lot of like cool
filmmakers and people that are you know
in the same kind of uh on the same path
as you so you you know exchange
information and get to know people that
way what do you do you just don't I
don't do any of those things that you
just mentioned but sounds good it sounds
like that's probably the right answer to
give yeah if you were contrasting
answers which would be his answer versus
my answer is a much much better answer
your answer my answer is just kind of my
answer just kind of
like but you also like do you like how
often do you stop by your agents you
just said you're five your agent yeah I
don't have an agent how did you get this
last job uh I have a manager oh okay
that's good manag but you sometimes you
have to like you have to stop by your
agents and your managers and kind of put
your face in there I think it's been
about four years since I've seen my
manager last face to face are you
serious yeah you know I'm just not very
I don't do these things I don't to have
a Twitter account and I don't go to the
manager's office I don't know I should
probably do it I probably should get to
work on these things I just hate doing
it can't understand it I like to live in
the delusion that that that working you
know doing good work at the moment as
best you can is the important thing but
that's probably totally [__] in this
day and age I think that yeah I think
that you probably have to do more than
more than that
yeah oh well oh well Twitter here I
come maybe I should tweet my agent right
now hey I fired you remember hey agent
tweet on this what do you even tweet
what do I say in a tweet hey guys
getting interviewed right now I could
that's what I could I I could tweet be
like hey interview right now doing
interview with film courage don't forget
to check it out can't you just tweet
this video put this video in a tweet
tweet this tweet this people would love
that you should have a shirt that says
tweet this it's got an arrow point down
to your dick I should tweet I should
should have I don't know why I don't
have that it's kind of an injustice I
don't have that shirt yet yet being the
key word give me a few days kids and a
may not have the shirt but I will have
it written sharp on my chest with arrow
probably misspelled oh yeah certainly
it'll be like backwards cuz of looking
in the mirror tweet spell tweet what
does [__] this mean [__] this tweet this